allora ragazzi non so come ve la cavate
vuoi di segnare ma io faccio pena allora
appena è sempre meglio di appena 2
appena il pacchetto davvero schifo ma
non so cosa riuscita a farmi genio metà
e metà tu e se che non le prende vita da
quanto è visto frankestein va bè ragazzi
let's go facciamo una roma un po diversa
oggi si chiama scrive il punto io provo
a vedere cosa riusciamo a disegnare come
scegliere la parola ma si tocca a te tu
devi scegliere allora altre parole su
strane io vado di vista lo sa in
italiano in inglese almeno lo sappiamo
noi italiano voglio trovare il cuore
giudeo cell sedia a sedia sono italiano
perché noi stiamo parlando sta sparando
cinque stelle da quattro ho capito non
valorizzare questa disegnare contare
allo stesso momento è una cannuccia una
torta è un cappio e un corda la corda
qualcuno ricorda ecco quella è la mia
voglia di vivere soprattutto però non
era male vai vai su realpower perché
cerchio e un orologio con delle unghie
al posto delle lancette e quindi come si
può dire orologio prestiamo cos'altro
minuti ore a cronometro croci to male
però minuti secondi secondi dai vettori
secondi esistono altri modi di dire le
parole non posso dirti altro aiuto
no non lo devo dire non lo devo dire
sono altri modi di dire le parole questa
era la stessa fare la prossima notte si
dica singolare te l'ho detto va bene
allora vista che parole a ok sono un
esperto e all'insegna st roma ok
preparatevi perché è una roba
incredibile uomo no aspetta i cancelli
vabbè ma questa è passato volevo mettere
uno che vi ha frustato sono in cina ma
avreste capito dai guarda quanto è
arrabbiato il tizio naso naso
bruttissimo narici narice match non è
fatto da cash ed all'uso ma entra
che aria vicinissimo ramarro respiro
scrivi
ero luca giurato in questo momento tutti
buona fortuna per molto a cuore leggero
letto sottile dormire dormire sono sogni
non lo capisco il suo team zanè
telecamere nel sonno
dovete ampliare le cose che pensa te è
un insulto davvero rimarrà minuto e
minuti adesso dovete cercare di
comprendere ed è una parola che avete
già scritto però resa verbo insultando
sogniare sogniare sogniare sognando
sognare
abbiamo vinto io e lei dentro te l'ho
scritto io come così perché non mi ha
scritto che casini aveva subito sogno
poi vi siete persi se ti ho messo una
parolaccia nel sogno staff c'è distratto
avete presente con the roar avviato
quello di prima ma questo ancora peggio
ancora più arrabbiata col a sparare
sparare sparare sparare
l'assassino cos'è e bellissimo non sinai
prima n
ora guardate il getto che importa è il
getto che importa se possono dirsi
cos'era quando dico devo fare punta è
stato con lei si capisce guardate questo
bene è perfetto se non ti va di farlo
meglio non ha capito lanciafiamme cavolo
proiettili non piove devi fare più fuoco
lama migliaia di tristezza allora devo
fare un omino anche io che stavolta ok
che mi è felice dai netini avremo così
così così e poi facciamo cpm alto
all'angelico cos'è cervello da capire
perché tipo lui in mano questo che va
qui è il carabiniere non capite nulla
litio 8 ma felici a ok sta rifugiando la
macchina in italiano infatti io pensavo
stesse sparando la macchina ma fare
non so come fare ma io non vedo niente
normale ok a perché non sta disegnando
cos'è il sale e il contenitore del c è
una tassa poi non è nata così una tappa
quella allora aspetta è maledizione è
conosciuto sulla punta della lingua
io stoccolma asset è cretino da il che
si capisce se possiamo capirlo regata e
isis bene per chiusi qual cosa giusta
però se no al casinò che cosa questa
attore parole è una specie di paraocchi
un po strano sono delle cuffiette brutti
e una doppia piastrina di limone ma non
ci sta che non ci sta veramente ceduti
per le bustine profonde turbino
altrimenti non certo la fila del furbina
non so di che cos'è questo è veramente
un casino
la parola vetro p2 ha fatto il tratto
grosso c'è un motivo buco nero
aspetta aspetta che fa un casino ma che
cosa sta pensando oggi in testa
guardando il video pensate a piedi su un
mostro
queste le sc pinson ben 67 dei problemi
nuovo sarà ma vengo molto più grasso
molto più grosso ma cosa sono quelli di
sopra del braccio gamba sceso da scambi
sincero non mi viene in mente niente ma
che sta scappando fortissimo perché lui
lo sta minando lo sta menando ok ed è
così grosso perché un panda
questo è un panda e come si chiama fare
come chiamano iscritto ma va davvero
accogli e kong fu panda gli incontri a
fare il governo seconda banche nei
giochi di disegno mib atti ma questo
caso ma come è possibile
come fai a battermi giochi di disegno
che ho capito prima era solo quello di
gare non era un jack audio fumato infine
le cong fu premi mettono male ai ragazzi
mentre loro litigano rilascio
porca miseria mamma mia spero che mi sia
piaciuta ringrazio steppe ferie trovate
loro cani descrizione ci saranno altri
disegni con loro perché veramente
bellissimi come se vi è piaciuto al
momento mi piace chiedevi al canale sono
stati iscritti che capo la campanella
principale notifiche e noi ci vediamo
present omo video da ragazzo
[Musica]